get hurt
every once in a while as president you
get to invite close friends into the
oval
i was kidding these guys before this is
american labor and i
said from the beginning my campaign
throughout my whole career
the middle class built this country and
labor built the middle class
and i think we have an incredible
opportunity to make some
enormous progress in creating jobs good
paying jobs davis bacon prevailing wage
jobs to rebuild the infrastructure of
this country in a way that everybody
knows has to be done
i promise a lot of these folks have been
my friends for a long
long long time as they say in parts of
my state these are the folks that bring
me to the dance
and uh and i appreciate their friendship
and as i said when somebody ran here
when i was with the business community
i said i want to make it clear i'm a
labor guy and there's no reason why it's
inconsistent with business growing
either so
what we're doing here today we're i ask
them to come in we want to talk about
the recovery act we have here that we
that we're trying to pass i think is
going to get done and building
infrastructure in this country
we are so far behind the curve we rank
something like 38th in the world in
terms of our infrastructure
everything from canals to highways
to airports to everything we can do and
we need to do to make ourselves
competitive in the 21st century
and so the vice president are looking
forward to this meeting
and we're going to have a good
conversation and
i think you know american workers
and the whole economy is going to grow
in a way that
we haven't seen it grow in a long time
this is a time for us to move so
anyway i'll let you know we're going to
have a long conversation here
i don't know how long we'll have a
conversation as long as they're willing
to put up with me
and talk about how we're going to get
this done so thank you all for coming in
this year mr president what did you
learn from americans last night about
what they want in this plan
i learned based on the polling data they
want everything is in the plan
not a joke everything is in the plan
i uh the fact is that i'd like to
i asked a rhetorical question those who
oppose the plan
what don't they like what particular
program don't they like don't they want
to help people with
nutrition don't they want to help people
be able to pay their mortgage
don't they want to help people get their
unemployment insurance don't they want
to make sure that people are able to
stay in their homes without being thrown
out of their homes in the middle of this
god-awful pandemic what don't they like
and uh the truth of the matter is
pulling data from last night and all the
polls you've all done they come from you
guys
not you personally but your networks and
your organizations
show that somewhere between 64 and 69
percent of the american people think we
have to do this
and uh it's uh it's not about
the money it's about in order to do
everything from
open schools as we should to make sure
that we're generating
income for people who are in real
trouble uh it's about
how much it costs federal government has
to chip in
make sure we get this done and as i said
almost every major economist in the
country and international monetary fund
as well says
it's going to grow the economy and
that's what we're talking about here
we're going to talk about how we grow
the economy so thank you all for coming
you said a return to normalcy could
happen by christmas what does that look
like mr president
thank you thank you very much